Ngay hấp lâu phần chiến tại nhà chắng, tổ thống bị đuán sông tin bồn Washington sẽ không chất thật bất kì ké hoạch nào, nhằm sát nập mơ tay, không nên mạnh đã để lúc phải dừng lại,
nông thời gui thống biệt sổ rằng, Thời Faker QQ is around, vốn mồ dọc lạnh thổ và chấm giết viện cảnh nhà nước Lestine.
Phá biểu được đưa ra sau cuộc gặp sự ông Trump và nhiều lãnh đạo các nước Aropoj Zao, bên lệ đã hội đồng lý hợp quốc,
các nước Aropoj Zao kinh bảo rằng, hành động sám nhập sẽ nơi khu vực vào vòng sợi cân tham mới trong khi nhiều đồng mình cũng bị ý như pháp, anh, các là đa ước sửa lia và bù đồng nhà cũng đã tôn gặp nhận nhất Lestine,
có đỏ là cách vui chi giải pháp hành nhất nước, Washington mới đầy cuộc mời đưa ra kế hoạch khăn miếm móc điểm khi vọng sơm đạt được phó bình cho giải gà ra.
Cục chiến gần hai năm qua đã khiến sổn bước lắm nghiền rồi thị mạc.
Cúc trong ngày hôm nay thần trên, tổng thống Pellec Thin ở mạm mút a bác biểu trực tuyến tại đại hội đồng lý hợp quốc,
thẳng định lực lượng hà mác sẽ thông của bác trò trong chính quyền Pellec Thin từng lại,
ông nhận mạng mọi thay phá hút chang và giá nâu của khi cho chính quyền Pellec Thin,
nông thời lên an chuẩn nghiệm bài sọ thái, thẳng định các phụ tấn công bệnh thổ isran của lượng hà mác không đại gì hết, cho nhận dần Pellec Thin.